[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo
bonjour ni cas on va voir ensemble ce
qui a été cette nouvelle semaine
politique et parlementaire très chargé
et d'autres invités cette semaine c'est
hervé mariton bonjour bonjour est député
les républicains de la drôme maire de
crest dans la drôme membres du conseil
de campagne de françois fillon alors
dans l'actualité cette semaine les
députés ont voté une projet de loi qui
modifie les règles d'usagé des armes
pour les policiers la cour des comptes a
rendu son rapport elle juge le budget
trop optimistes
et puis françois fillon évidemment on va
en parler le tente de reprendre la main
sur sa campagne après les semaines des
révélations et on va commencer tout de
suite par le projet de loi sur la
sécurité publique qui était débattu en
séance publique cette semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
débattue et votée en séance publique ce
projet de loi fait suite aux incidents
de viry châtillon en octobre dernier où
des policiers avaient été brûlés vifs au
cocktail molotov le projet de loi a été
voté donc mercredi alors que la sphère
de l'agression d'aulnay-sous-bois
suscité réactions et émotions compte
rendu de séance avec bastien auger qui
est pour l'adoption du texte
quand projet de loi adopté à l'unanimité
parmi la quinzaine de députés présents
la droite et le front national ont joint
leurs voix à celles de la majorité sur
le dernier texte sécuritaire du
quinquennat il définit notamment des
règles communes d' usage d armes entre
policiers nationaux et gendarmes
il étend la protection de l'anonymat des
enquêteurs et double les peines
encourues pour outrage à agent le vote
d'hier n'efface pas les critiques
virulentes du texte notamment chez les
magistrats et les avocats critique
relayée mardi dans l'hémicycle par une
partie de la gauche
autre loi en renforçant les possibilités
de tir à vue en risquant par là même des
morts supplémentaires en aggravant les
qualifications d'outragé de rébellion à
graver ou risque d'aggraver les
fractures et attise des plaies
existantes
la droite elle avait jugé le texte trop
tardif
votre gouvernement aura traversé cette
législature sans écouter les
propositions de l'opposition vous y
venez aujourd'hui naturellement nous ne
pouvons que nous en réjouir
mais que de temps perdu trop de temps
perdu par rapport à un sujet extrêmement
grave
le projet de loi a encore un peu de
chemin les députés et les sénateurs
doivent trouver un compromis
dès la semaine prochaine en commission
mixte paritaire le texte semble bien
parti pour être définitivement adopté
avant la fin de la législature alors
hervé mariton il semblerait qu'il y ait
un possible accord sur ce texte et qui
fait donc l'unanimité c'est assez rare
ces derniers temps notamment à
l'assemblée est ce que pour vous cette
loi est nécessaire ce que c'est une loi
de consensus aussi je pense qu'elle est
utile et nécessaire elle est nécessaire
pour renforcer les capacités d'action de
la police et on a vu que c'était
tout à fait souhaitable y compris quand
on fait la comparaison historique avec
les possibilités d'action des gendarmes
qui sont jusqu'à présent
significativement plus puissante que
celle des policiers et le deuxième point
qui est la protection juridique le
renforcement des sanctions de la mise en
cause des forces de l'ordre et quelque
chose tout à fait justifiée ensuite en
particulier après les événements de
l'année on voit bien qu'il y a un
problème grave dans notre pays qui est
un problème de relation entre les forces
de l'ordre et un son de citoyens la
solution à cela je le dis avec toute les
prudences qu'on doit à l'appréciation
des faits d'aulnay qui est complexe mais
on voit bien qu'une des clés
c'est à la fois la réponse juridique bon
l'assemblée fait petit progrès et en
même temps quelque chose qui n'est pas
tant de l'ordre du droit mais de l'ordre
de la pratique et le respect le respect
mutuel et le respect vous l'entendez
dans les manifestations qui ont eu lieu
encore toute la semaine après les
incidents donné il ya plus de respect
que ce soit de la police envers cette
jeunesse des quartiers notamment
et là les novillos surfer gassion
quelques pas manifestement il ya un
problème oui donc il ya quelque chose de
cassé je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
affronter la réalité telle qu'elle est
et à la fois iliad à part d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens d'habitants de
certains quartiers de notre pays plus
particulièrement une forme d'hostilité
systématique non seulement à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre mais à l'égard de tout
ce qui représente l'autorité ça peut
être les pompiers parfois alors même
qu'ils viennent vous portez des secours
et il y a de l'autre côté des écarts qui
ne sont pas acceptables on a ce policier
utilisant le terme de choqué le
terme est manifestement inappropriées et
irrespectueux ensuite ça mériterait une
sanction
je ne sais pas il y à des affaires de
contexte et sam c'est au minimum
inapproprié je ne suis pas sûr que ça
relève d'une qualification pénale
mais en tout cas ça mérite
au minimum un rappel à l'ordre ce qui
est en soi une forme de sanction
oui qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
aujourd'hui pour essayer de remettre du
lien dans cette police parce qu'on voit
bien aussi et marine le pen l'a dit dans
une émission de télévision que la moitié
des policiers des gendarmes ont décidé
de voter pour elle
ça veut dire qu'elle elle prône
finalement qu'il ya un abandon de la
droite comme de la gauche de cette
police et de cette gendarmerie
je pense en tout cas pour ce qui nous
concerne la droite dans la campagne de
françois fillon qu'il est alors très
important d'affirmer ce qu'est notre
engagement sur ces question d'autorité
sur ces questions de sécurité affaire de
moyens nous proposons de mettre des
moyens supplémentaires pour la
gendarmerie pour la police pour la
justice mais aussi à faire de cadre
juridique est affaire de comportement et
je vais dire les choses il faut par
exemple que des forces de l'ordre soient
toujours d'un absolu respect à l'égard
des citoyens
on fait souvent la comparaison avec les
britanniques ou d'autres pays en europe
où ses problèmes de relations sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes
ça veut dire qu'il ya pas de temps en
temps des émeutes de banlieues des
émeutes urbaines en angleterre aussi
mais il y a d'autres dimensions qu'il
faut aussi regarder sans céder pour
autant une espèce de de politiquement
correct dit réalisme ou d'inconscience
des choses je vais dire quelque chose de
la république et faire des choses de
jeunes très politiquement non correct je
l'assumé essayé de dire et à caution
mais j'entendais sur une antenne il ya
quelques jours
spécialiste de ces questions de sécurité
de banlieue qui disait mais c'est
choquant il y a dans les contrôles
d'identité qui sont faits en france il y
à une proportion importante de personnes
originaires de de tels quartiers où avec
telle ou telle origine ethnique clé on
va pas non plus établir des quotas est
dit
il il faut tel pourcentage de contrôle
de personnes qui ressemble à ça tel
pourcentage
et puis pour des raisons de
politiquement correct on va faire en
sorte que des gens qui n'ont pas de
raisons a priori d'être contrôlé par la
police de vienne il peut y avoir des
gens parfaitement gauloise allure que la
police ait envie de contrôler parce
qu'elle a besoin de le faire mais on va
pas rentrer dans une politique de quotas
là dessus je dis simplement cela donc
voilà il est important que la police
contrôler les situations qu'elle a
besoin de contrôler je le dis au delà de
la question du contrôle
la question du respect alors oui on va
parler de finances publiques
oui spécialistes cette semaine la cour
des comptes a rendu son rapport assez
sévère pour les comptes publics
[Musique]
les dépenses de l'état ont été épinglés
la cour des comptes dénonce aussi
notamment le fiasco de l'écotaxe et met
en garde sur le met en garde également
sur les finances publiques
c'est un rapport sévère pour le
gouvernement la cour des comptes juge
que ses prévisions budgétaires sont trop
optimistes dans le budget 2010 est le
gouvernement prévoyait de ramener le
déficit public à 2 7% du pib soit une
réduction de 0 6%
un objectif très difficile à atteindre
selon les magistrats financiers
les facteurs qui ont joué positivement
ces dernières années ne joueront plus on
voit bien que les taux d'intérêt
remontent que la contribution de la
france au budget l'union européenne à
vocation aussi à a augmenté à nouveau
et puis qu'il y à un certain nombre de
contraintes qui tiennent un certain
nombre de choix souverains qui ont été
faits par notre pays notamment en
matière de dépenses de sécurité
intérieure et extérieure
côté recettes c'est la prévision de
croissance qui serait trop optimiste
d'après les magistrats les dépenses
elles seront plus élevées que prévu
notamment pour l'assurance maladie et
l'indemnisation chômage
pendant la discussion budgétaire
l'opposition avait déjà tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé
le rapport de la cour des comptes
conforte son inquiétude du côté des
dépenses là c'est vraiment très
inquiétant
la dépense publique repart à la hausse
et en particulier la cour des comptes a
raison de souligner que la masse
salariale
rendez vous compte la masse salariale
des fonctionnaires de l'état va
augmenter en 2010 est davantage
davantage qu entre 2011 et 2016
donc en une seule année en 2017 on va
avoir une augmentation supérieure à tout
ce qu'on a connu pendant cinq ans à
gauche on assume ce bilan financier du
quinquennat en demi teinte ce rapport
montrent surtout les
les efforts qu'il convient de continuer
à accomplir un certain nombre ont été
faits la cour des comptes juge que ce
n'est pas suffisant mais
elle ne nie pas qu'il y ait eu des
efforts ces dernières années mais il est
clair qu'il en faudra d'autres
dans ce rapport la cour des comptes
dénonce également le fiasco de l'écotaxe
cette taxation des poids lourds imaginé
sous l'ère sarkozy
le gouvernement socialiste ya renoncé
face à la fronde des bonnets rouges son
abandon à d'ores et déjà coûté près d'un
milliard d'euros à l'état
alors rien fait ma raison parlons de
l'écotaxe tu connais bien ce sujet vous
avez déposé un rapport il ya eu des
discussions une mission ici à
l'assemblée tout ça pour pour sa finale
manquée ce q quel est votre sentiment
par rapport ce que dit la cour des
comptes ce gâchis
l'accord est content a raison c'est un
gâchis que je suis volontaire c'est un
caprice de ségolène royal et la
mansuétude la bienveillance ou
l'indifférence l'inconscience ou
prennent leur sens que vous voulez avec
laquelle ce type de gaspillage et applis
de notre pays est ahurissant on aurait
pu les banques on en reparlera tout à
l'heure on a parfois des polémiques et
voilà non c'est l'avis des mesures des
sujets dont les ordres de grandeur sont
pas du tout les mêmes ou des mois j'ai
publié un rapport en 2011 j'étais à
l'époque rapporteur spécial du budget
des transports
aujourd'hui rapporteur du budget de
l'écologie j'avais dit attention cette
affaire dans tous les pays en europe est
compliqué dans la mise en oeuvre et en
2012 le gouvernement a été extrêmement
léger là-dessus léger dans les
conditions pratiques de mise en place et
les jets dans le traitement de la
pédagogie et de la discussion autour les
bonnets rouges
et puis ensuite d'un meilleur de sa
série vais demander à mon collègue
socialiste chanteur gay qui présidait là
la mission laquelle j'ai moi même
participé à la difficulté d'un coup un
caprice de ces graines variable oui mais
la difficulté monsieur ça veut dire ça
fait cher la montre ce que nous avions
commencé de faire avec la majorité de
l'époque
mais ça veut dire ensuite géré la
situation tenir compte des travaux
parlementaires notre travail sans
majorité matin ségolène royal se
réveille elle décide de manière
capricieuse et manifestement d'antan
tensions avec son secrétaire d'état aux
transports et elle jette par les
fenêtres saisit pas autrement
un milliard d'euros les contribuables
français qui nous regardent et le
président endroit c'était le prix de
quoi selon vous
se débarrasser d'un sujet un caprice
mais elle avait commencé déjà quelques
mois avant en traitant par dessus la
jambe
légende ecomouv en ayant un très grand
mépris pour des procédures complexes qu
avait été menée donc que la gestion
concrète sur la politique c'est de
l'accord y ont pu lancer des médias mais
parfois c'est aussi si on regarde le
ciel plus lourde que si mal royal se
mettaient un peu plus dans les dossiers
ça se passerait mieux si la droite
revenue au pouvoir l'écotaxe vous
l'armée terrier sur sur le devant de la
scène aujourd'hui vous remettra y ait
cette loi en place je ne vais pas engagé
françois fillon là dessus je ne suis pas
habilité à le faire mais je peux vous
dire un que la question des péages
d'infrastructures est une question qui
se pose partout sur la planète et nous
n'avons pas de tabou là dessus
et deuxièmement un système type écotaxe
je ne dis pas qu'il faut faire
exactement la chance parce que
malheureusement
enfin seulement marcher donc forcément
il fallait voir peut-être autre chose
non seulement mais les dispositifs ont
été assez largement caisse paye est
certes un portique ont été des banques
les les systèmes informatiques ont été
bradés la cour des comptes le dénonce
répondait courte elle dénonce aussi le
budget de l'état aujourd'hui qui est le
déficit qui serait assez important est
ce que vous estimez vous qu'il y aura
des données une cachette en 2017
écoutez moi je suis le porte-parole du
groupe républicain à l'assemblée la
commission des finances je suis ça
depuis plusieurs mois je suis d'accord
avec la cour des comptes dans une double
dimension
il y à un certain nombre de dérapages
budgétaires qui sont inscrits en 2010
est là par ailleurs des engagements que
le gouvernement a pris et donc il faudra
payer l'addition en cours d'année là et
puis aussi en 2018 en même temps il faut
qu'on ait la sagesse ça a été des
discussions à la fin d'année dernière
vous en souvenez de ne pas surévaluer ça
c'est à dire que voilà le déficit va
plutôt dépassée évidemment les 3,5 3,7
on va probablement aller vers quelque
chose qui sera entre 3,5 et 4 il faut
pas charger la barque déraisonnablement
c'est pas parce que je suis dans
l'opposition
jeudi 1 le gouvernement a menti de la
cour des comptes le dit hélas le solde
budgétaire sera bien pire que ce qui a
été annoncé par le gouvernement mais il
faut pas en rajouter quatre doses qui
sinon nous exonérerait d'une vertu
budgétaire qui est indispensable c'est
je vois bien le schéma que j'ai combattu
y compris dans des débats notre schéma
qui amène à charger la barque
histoire de se faciliter la gestion
début de mandat ça a été fait par des
majorités de droite et de gauche
actualité c'est jamais bon ben
maintenant on va parler de françois
fillon est le candidat toute la semaine
à essayer de se remettre en selle
conférence de presse et puis retour sur
le terrain bien évidemment revoit toute
la semaine de françois fillon lundi 16h
françois fillon convoque la presse à son
qg de campagne
250 journalistes français et étrangers
sont présents
le candidat de la droite s'explique sur
l' affaire qui a bouleversé sa campagne
il fait son mea culpa en travaillant
avec ma femme et mes enfants j'ai
privilégié cette collaboration de
confiance qui aujourd'hui suscite la
défiance
c'était une erreur je le regrette
profondément et je présente mes excuses
ou france
des excuses et une contre attaque
immédiate été choisi par des millions de
français je ne suis pas le candidat d'un
parti
aucune instance n'a la légitimité pour
remettre en cause le vote de la primaire
sûr de lui le candidat de la droite
reprend la main il resserre son comité
de campagne et réunit les parlementaires
de la droite et du centre pour les
rassurer
à la sortie c'est l'union sacrée a
bénéficié du soutien voire de la nation
de tous les parlementaires et nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une logique de
conquête avec un chef une équipe un
projet et une volonté de convaincre les
français l'heure est à la mobilisation
les explications étaient données la
justice suit son cours mais maintenant
on est mobilisé pour gagner la
présidentielle plus personne ne parle de
plan d il faut être réaliste
alain juppé n'ira pas il l'a dit il n'ya
pas d'autre alternative possible donc
c'est encore une fois le projet tout le
projet le programme tout le programme et
rien que le projet pour l'alternance n'y
a pas d'autre solution
sur le terrain la campagne repart dès
mardi à troyes dans l'aube
aux côtés du maire françois baroin et
devant un parterre d'entrepreneurs
locaux
au même moment une nouvelle tombe le
canard enchaîné révèle que pénélope
fillon aurait touché 45000 euros
d'indemnités de licenciement payé par
l'assemblée nationale
réaction de françois fillon lapidaire
droit sur son chemin après deux semaines
de révélations françois fillon enchaîne
les déplacements ce jeudi à poitiers et
ce week-end en outre-mer étude qui est
tombé à cette fête semaine sept français
sur dix pensent que françois fillon
devrait renoncer même dans votre camp ce
chiffre augmente parce que ça va finir
comme cela
d'abord dans ce jeu si vous avez un
paquet de français de gauche ou même à
droite proche du front national enfin
chacun sait je le sais vous le savez
chacun sait que les français ont été
troublés qui est des questions
françois fillon a été amené à exprimer
des regrets à exprimer les excuses et
maintenant il faut qu'on avance
je crois que aujourd'hui chacun voit
c'est bien vous pouvez dans ce cas il ya
peut-être eu un chef de nous deux choix
inapproprié par françois fillon
et ils sont en tout cas perçu comme ça
par un nombre important de français et
paré du perchoir les choix de l'ensemble
de ce qui a été évoqué sur eux
vous voyez bien que les enfants
comprennent la mort à 20 points bien cru
demande membres de la famille qui ont
posé des questions là-dessus mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça
il est important de rappeler que tout
cela n'est pas illégal et que vous ne
pouvez pas reprocher à quelqu'un ce
n'est pas sain en démocratie
un comportement qui n'est pas illégal
l'avocat françois fillon est-il que la
justice en tout cas le parquet national
financier n'a pas à se mêler de la
manière dont le député emploi son
enveloppe si je puis dire
la justice n'a pas semé les deux ça vous
dit qu'il faut c'est pas c'est un vrai
sujet de séparation de vouloir d'abord
il est tout de même important de
rappeler que l'enveloppent elle est
définie a priori le parlementaire ne la
gonfle pas et donc c'est un vrai sujet
d'une certaine manière la vision
séparation des pouvoirs l ai dit si on
l'a l'exposent de manière très très très
puissante elle et de dire ben voilà il y
à son de moyens qui sont confiées aux
parlementaires l'ampleur de ces moyens
est connu ensuite c'est leur
responsabilité
destiné si vous estimez que c'est mal
employé c'est votre responsabilité
politique en tant qu'électeur d'en tirer
des conséquences
mais avec un respect très fort la
séparation des pouvoirs moi je vois bien
aujourd'hui
quand j'entends les revendications les
analyses des uns et des autres tout ça
est loisible mais que le curseur est
poussé très loin
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui posent la
question de la révocation des
parlementaires en cours de mandat vous
avez un appel très fort à la démocratie
directe est au fond un choix immédiat
par les citoyens vous avez vous seriez
mise en cause la démocratie
représentative
vous avez une revendication forte de
mandat impératif la révocation
la démocratie directe la manière dont on
reçoit selon de deux demandes de
citoyens ça ressemble beaucoup à du
mandat impératif si vous avez le mandat
impératif la mise en cause de la
représentation à un moment il ya plus de
parlement je pense que c'est pas bon
pour la démocratie je ne dis pas de
manière corporatiste je peux être député
un jour ne pas l'être un autre sujet
n'est pas là mais je pense que la vie du
pays va mieux avec l'existence d'une
représentation et avec on on est ici
devant des antennes parlementaire avec
véritablement ce rôle qui est celui des
représentants de la nation et donc je
pense que nous ne soit pas se prononcer
quand il ya des affaires de
parlementaires j'ai absolument pas dit
ça si un parlementaire brûle un feu
rouge ou si un parlementaire assassine
quelqu'un d'emploi responsables devant
la justice
quand on rentre dans le fonctionnement
du parlement je dis simplement que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que bon on
sait où ça commence on sait pas
exactement où ça s'arrête
il ya un moment si vous fixez trop peu
de règles ça ne va pas si vous en fixer
trop c'est l'autonomie des
parlementaires vous mettez en cause
l'autonomie
par rapport à l'injonction quotidienne
qui peut leur être adressés l'autonomie
par rapport à leur parti et je le dis
c'est une vraie question d'ailleurs en
amont l'info que les citoyens se disent
les parlementaires ont telle capacité
d'action est ce que je lui en confie la
responsabilité
et oui ou non je vote pour lui et puis à
la fin du mandat
est-ce que je considère cette
responsabilité a été bien exercer toutes
les questions sont loisible on est bien
d'accord
toutes les questions sont loisible
toutes les sanctions ne sont pas
légitimes
hervé mariton en avance et on va
reparler de vous comment vous situez
notamment dans la campagne à droite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on en parle avec jim jarrassé du
figaro.fr bonjour bonjour et matin le
baryton vous faites désormais partie du
comité de campagne
resserrée qui a été annoncé cette
semaine autour de françois fillon pour
relancer sa campagne après sa conférence
de presse
quelle place vous comptez occupé
précisément dans ce dispositif une place
active je suis membre de l'équipe projet
et françois fillon m'a demandé aussi de
de participer à ce comité de campagne
je mouille la chemise j'ai eu quelques
semaines d'absence en janvier du fait
d'un accident de santé
mais je reprends avec le terrain le mien
la drôme d'autres terrains nous avons
prévu à la fin de la semaine prochaine
de nous projeter très largement sur le
pays jénine rémois même certaines
réunions
je continue de travailler sur les idées
parce que c'est tout coeur j'ai été
responsable ya quelques années du projet
à l'ump
ma candidature aux primaires était
motivée par les enjeux de conviction
fondamentalement assumer totalement sur
le fond cette double dimension de
liberté et de valeurs qui est présente
dans la campagne de france faire partie
du cercle rapproché de françois fillon
s'était pas forcément évident pour vous
on se souvient de propos que vous avez
tenus pendant la campagne de la primaire
vous disiez on a retrouvé sa françois
fillon être les prémices de sarkozy il a
abîmé ont il a été abîmée pardon ensuite
par le combat que jean françois copé
bref il n'a aucune chance d'émerger et
aujourd'hui à la clé la primaire je me
suis complètement changé d'avis faisait
derrière lui vous avez oubliez tout ce
que vous avez toutes les critiques vous
allez moi je vais contrôler je n'ai pas
oublié ce que j'ai dit je dis simplement
qu'en démocratie un moment le vote
s'impose je viens de vous l'expliquer
d'une autre manière encore et écoutez
j'ai voulu être candidat aux primaires
ça y est ils fonctionnent et pour les
raisons de forme ça s'est arrêté je le
regrette je pense que c'est dommage pour
le débat mais voilà c'est comme ça
il ya eu un vote ce vote
françois fillon l'a remarquablement
gagner
un moment il pour vous il a émergé il va
gagner la présidentielle
à écouter la question de l'émergence si
je peux me permettre je n'avais pas fait
cette analyse manifestement il a émergé
il ya quelques millions de français qui
se sont chargés de le démontrer donc
baryton il pouvait penser ce qu'ils
voulaient mais à côté de la réflexion
profonde de votre serviteur il ya
plusieurs millions de français qui ont
décidé que françois fillon était leur
champion aujourd'hui c'est l'intérêt de
la france que françois fillon il ya une
ambiance du deuil agissements qu'on
entend partout c'est le risque
vous voyez bien mais en même temps
l'enjeu est important c'est pas un jeu
dans lequel on est je crains que tout le
monde fasse un jour ce moment que ce
soit entre marine le pen et emmanuel
mais le peuple est souverain en même
temps j'attire l'attention que oui
l'enjeu est tout à fait considérable et
que le projet qui est au fond la suite
de hollande porté par emmanuel macron le
projet tout à fait inadaptée sur les
principes sur le fond qui est celui de
marine le pen
les visions très à gauche d'amour ou de
mélenchon il ya un projet qui me paraît
plus efficace liberté économique
sinon je considérable qui est celui de
l'emploi et jean marc ailleurs
l'affirmation de valeurs et dans
l'extrême confusion
j'ai fait ma rentrée politique mardi en
réunissant vos mouvements et avait 300
personnes
ça a été un très beau moment que j'ai
développé mes amis je veux partager avec
vous cette idée que dans l'extrême
confusion actuelle on n'a pas besoin de
rajouter il y en a aux à la confusion
par l'illusion de macron par les
impasses de mélenchon il n'y a pas eu
danger est très loin de repères on a
besoin aussi de libérer certains restent
très critique avec françois fillon
notamment françois bayrou il est bon il
ay là il a émis des critiques cette
semaine on écoute je pensais que
françois fillon était quelqu'un qui
était absolument de ce point de vue là à
l'abri
je veux vous dire ceci jamais dans
l'histoire de la république un candidat
aux plus hautes fonctions à la
présidence de la république
n'a été ainsi sous l'influencé des
puissances d'argent sont des paroles
fortes qu'est ce que vous lui répondait
à françois bayrou
j'ai souvent eu un certain respect pour
françois bayrou mais je l' ai connu
mieux inspiré quand françois bayrou a
seule alerte ya quelques années sur
niveau de la dette de la france il eu
raison de le faire et françois fillon
est le seul aujourd'hui dans le débat à
venir fait gaffe françois bayrou ce de
nos persos lario sa souveraineté par
l'endettement américain
emmanuel macron lui-même aujourd'hui
fait l'impasse sur la question des
finances publiques et bear ou gelée
connu inspiré là dessus et heureusement
que fillon porte ce flambeau là je pense
que françois fillon s'est garé pardon je
pense que françois bayrou s'est excusé
moi et que françois fillon aujourd'hui
portent le flambeau et heureusement vous
craignez que se vouent créneau bayrou
soit soit candidat et qu'il puisse
piquer calvet libres de le faire je ne
sais pas si ça piquerez des voix à
fillon à maquereau ou à d'autres je
pense que ça ne clarifierait pas la
situation je le dis et je ne pense pas
que françois bayrou aujourd'hui à une
très grande valeur ajoutée apportée
avoir été déjà bien compliquée non je ne
dit pas jamais vous savez je voulais dit
j'ai une estime réel pour françois
bayrou
mais je pense qu'il faut d'abord
françois bayrou en 2012 a tout de même
pris une responsabilité grave en
facilitant l'élection de françois
hollande
chacun sait que beaucoup lui reprochent
chez nous mais si aujourd'hui il veut
revenir vers nous attendaient devant le
qu'il le fasse mais moi je considère que
rien n'est jamais désespérer françois
bayrou le bouchon tout de même un peu
loin que françois bayrou réfléchissent à
la responsabilité qu'il prend est ce
qu'il veut a ajouté la confusion à la
confusion
ou est-ce qu'au contraire il veut me
permettre qu'on réunisse les conditions
du rétablissement de la france et ça il
ya une réponse aujourd'hui il y en a pas
d'autre c'est l'élection de françois
fillon et d'un merci ce sera le mot de
la fin avait marre et on merci d'avoir
dénoncé à tous
[Musique]